obs mình lâu không livestream
nên là
update xong rồi có vẻ ổn định hơn rồi
các bạn
các bạn nghe thấy gì không ạ nghe rõ rồi
đúng không ạ
lâu lắm rồi không livestream mình xin
phép mình chia sẻ tâm sự qua đầu tiên
cái video này trước đã cho các bạn sẽ
nghe nghe qua video đã
video này chắc chắn sẽ không có nhiều
người xem nhưng mà đây sẽ là một cái bài
học rất là giá trị trong kinh doanh
bán hàng các bạn muốn bán đồ nó rẻ tại
vì các bạn nghĩ là khi mà các bạn bán rẻ
thì khách hàng họ cảm thấy là họ lời đây
là một sai lầm sự thật là khách hàng họ
không muốn mua hàng rẻ mà họ muốn mua
hàng họ cảm thấy lời cho họ đó là một
khác biệt rất là lớn mình lấy ví dụ đi 1
tỷ thì 1 tỷ có lẽ là một cái giá khá là
cao với chúng ta
alo alo
mình tắt tiếng đi mình chỉ phát video
ở quận nhất thế giới bạn không có 1 tỷ
nhưng mà bạn sẽ ngay lập tức Gọi điện
cho ba mẹ bạn gọi cho bạn bè bạn vay
mượn ngân hàng để mà có 1 tỷ đó đưa cho
mình Tại vì sao tại vì bạn biết cái giá
trị của căn nhà đó nó cao hơn rất là
nhiều so với cái giá 1 tỷ mà bạn phải
trả tự nhiên cái giá 1 tỷ đó nó lại
không thành vấn đề đúng không Thì trong
bất kỳ giao dịch nào cái giá là số tiền
mà bạn phải trả và giá trị là thứ mà bạn
nhận được và người ta muốn mua cái gì mà
người ta cảm thấy là cái giá trị mà họ
nhận được vượt xe so với cái giá mà họ
phải trả cho nên khi bạn kinh doanh nó
thay vì tập trung vào giá hãy tập trung
vào tăng cái giá trị để mà họ cảm thấy
là họ có một cái điều Lợi share video
này với bản thân của bạn còn nó có hiểu
không Ok
vừa livestream cái bị mất rồi Hình như
nó có cái thuật toán à để mình nhận diện
được Nếu mình không nói cái gì cả Mình
chỉ quay mình chỉ phát một cái gì đó
thôi thì nó sẽ tự động ngắt
thì cái video vừa rồi thì
có thể nói qua việc là là cái
gần đây gần đây mình có xem cái chương
trình là sang nhà triệu đô
cái chương trình truyền hình về kiểu về
cái nhà môi giới các thứ các thứ thì cậu
hôm nay cũng có cái câu hỏi ở vòng chung
kết Đó là kiểu
anh anh trả lời cũng Anh tên là Long
luôn anh đấy 27 tuổi ngủ Quốc Long thì
phải
anh đấy trả lời cái câu đó là
sẽ phải làm thế nào khi mà tình trạng
kiểu bây giờ là cứ bán phá giá bán hạ
giá các thứ các thứ thì thì
anh ấy nhận xét là kiểu không nên như
thế bởi vì kiểu đương nhiên khách hàng
ai cũng mong muốn là mình sẽ giảm giá
cho họ nhưng mà đó là bởi vì mình không
cho họ cái thứ mà họ cảm thấy xứng đáng
họ chả ra nên là họ mới cảm thấy là kiểu
mình mình bán giá cao quá họ mình muốn
giảm còn bản chất là còn bản chất là khi
mà họ Chả liên quan đến cả công việc các
bạn nữa đi làm bản chất là bạn đang bán
thức sáng bán công sức của mình đúng
không ạ Và họ sẽ và họ ở đây là khách
hàng chính là sếp các bạn chẳng hạn sẽ
người thuê các bạn thuê mua lại công sức
và chết giả các bạn thì thì bạn không
phải trả giá thấp là điêu lương thấp để
mà nhận được công việc không nên như thế
nghĩa là các bạn đang tự đánh giá thấp
bản thân mình đang tự làm bản thân mình
mất đi giá trị đúng không ạ lương thì
vẫn có thể nổ cao nhưng bạn vẫn phải
đúng là phải rất xứng đáng với mức lương
như thế thì bạn mới dám nổ bạn mới dám
nói không một công ty nào không tuyển
không muốn tuyển một người rất giỏi cả
cho dù kể cả lương họ cao gấp ba bốn lần
người bình thường họ vẫn sẵn sàng tuyển
bởi vì một người mà giỏi gấp 3 4 lần
người bình thường họ còn người đấy còn
hơn cả ba bốn người bình thường làm gộp
lại Bây giờ các bạn cứ hình dung một cái
dự án mà tận 3 4 người cùng làm ấy Ừ Thì
Nghe có vẻ nó có cái gì ổn nhưng nếu mà
ba bốn người với ba cái bốn cái đầu suy
nghĩ khác nhau ấy thì nó lại thành một
cái kiểu một cái hồ lớn thay vì như thế
chỉ còn một hoặc hai người rất là giỏi
rất là có chuyên môn làm rất là cẩn thận
và họ Họ có tư duy là làm đâu Chắc đến
đấy chẳng hạn thì nó ít sinh ra vấn đề
hơn so với kiểu nhiều người đấy do nhiều
công ty sẵn hàng tuyển những người rất
là giỏi kiểu dạng là lương của họ có thể
bằng dùng từ 10 người cũng đúng bằng 10
người khác ngủ lại đấy ở trong ngành này
là không nên hạ thấp bản thân thời gian
đầu thì đúng là mình chưa có kinh nghiệm
gì thật thì mình có thể làm thực tập
không Lương cái gì đó Nhưng sau khoảng
thời gian thực tập không Lương các bạn
làm được việc rồi thì các bạn nên phải
làm được việc nhé không nói việc là các
bạn vẫn chưa làm được việc mà đã đòi
lương đâu nhé các bạn làm được việc rồi
thì các bạn phải nhận ra được giá trị
bản thân và các bạn sẽ phải điêu lương
lại nếu mà công ty đấy mà vẫn thích bóc
lột bạn vẫn kiểu dạng vẫn chưa trả lương
xứng đáng thì bạn hãy sẵn sàng nên nghỉ
và chuyển sang công ty khác Nói chung là
tôi vẫn theo phương châm từ trước đến
nay tôi bảo mấy ông đó là biết mình biết
ta đúng không ạ nghĩa là biết được năng
lực của mình như thế nào để mà để mà
kiểu biết được ưu nhược của mình như thế
nào
Nhược thì mình đương nhiên là tìm cách
khắc phục hoặc là biến nó thành yêu càng
tốt và Còn yêu thì chắc chắn là các bạn
phải tận dụng nó là
Tắt bớt mấy cái
tự nhiên tôi đang kết nối cái mạng Long
này không Để tôi đổi xem
nói chung là kiểu xong sau cái quãng
thời gian này mình nghĩ là mình có học
hỏi thêm được rất rất nhiều Tự nhiên là
kiểu dân công nghệ thông tin nhưng lại
biết chạy chạy kiểu làm chương trình
xong rồi Kiểu làm MC rồi đủ kiểu tất cả
là đúng nghĩa là vì đam mê vì cộng đồng
là là chính đấy bởi vì à mình tôi gần
như là tôi đang kiểu gần như chạy
chạy làm rất nhiều thứ
cũng may mà cũng nhờ được một vài người
để mà hỗ trợ cùng robot
được tiếng Hiện tại tôi đang như thế nào
đâu
xem chậm hơn một tí là không không
livestream trực tiếp được chắc thế
để chế độ là
phim Setting là
Ultra lâu à Cái này nó sẽ không ổn định
nó lắm thì phải
khoảng thời gian nó thành bất bình
thường anh ạ
cho các bạn bảo vệ đồ án nhé từng nhóm
vào link này để mà bảo vệ đồ án
alo em nghe rồi không nhỉ
Ok nhóm em trước bắt đầu luôn đi Hôm nay
thật ra là mình kiểu hơi gấp nên thành
ra mình cũng không mời được thầy thầy
nào cả Hôm nay mình sẽ bảo vệ riêng với
các bạn thôi vậy các bạn cứ bảo vệ xong
rồi à
Bên em mình sẽ có thêm Nhận xét những
cái là cuối buổi thì các bạn giống như
có bạn kia bình luận ý thì các bạn sẽ
gửi lại cho mình CV để mà mình có thể
đánh giá qua các bạn chấm qua CV các bạn
nữa để mà
có thể gửi cv cho mình để mình chấm vào
thậm chí là có thể thích thì có thể về
bên mình để mà
kiểu thực tập cũng được hoặc là đăng
mình mình có mình có kiểu đăng rất nhiều
cái JD của các bạn khác của các bên công
ty khác để các bạn phải ứng tuyển ý Nói
chung là các bạn có thể kiểu gửi lại cv
trong mình để mình duyệt hoặc
Hoặc là nếu mà lý tưởng hơn ấy thì tôi
nghĩ là mấy ông đang sờ CV lên cái nhóm
công khai ở trên discord để mà không
phải mỗi mình tôi mà các nhóm các bạn
khác cũng thể xem góp ý và đánh giá qua
cũng được bởi vì tôi đánh giá thì cũng
chỉ là mang tính kiểu khách quan à chủ
quan là nhiều Bởi tôi cũng không chuyên
hẳn cái này lắm Tôi chỉ theo cấp độ nhìn
của tôi thôi đúng không ạ thì các bạn cứ
đăng CV lên nhóm discord xong rồi các
bạn để các bạn Tự góp ý và tham khảo lẫn
nhau và càng tốt đúng không ạ
nhóm em làm về
làm về đề tài là quản lý sân bóng gồm có
em là thành viên là Nguyễn Trung Thiện
lý do chọn đề tài thì
giúp giúp khách hàng có thể giúp khách
hàng có thể khi mà đặt sân bóng thì có
thể lựa chọn được thời gian hợp lý và
hiển thị những cái khung giờ hiển thị
những khung giờ mà đã được người khác
đặt giúp cho người giúp cho người quản
lý có thể nắm được lịch đặt sân
nắm được số liệu cụ thể của các sân
áp dụng thì PSP
hàng ngoài quản trị viên
xong Tìm kiếm đặt sang
xem chi tiết xong
về quản trị viên thì có thể xin có thể
quản lý các khu vực Xem lịch đặt xem
lịch đặt của các khu vực thêm Sơn
tìm kiếm tìm kiếm các sân và các giữa
các đơn của của cái lịch đặt của xăng
lắm
đây là sơ đồ thực tế
sân
đặt sân cho
đặt xong
và cái sân Thì thì gồm có các khu vực
của sân đó
chắc là vậy Ok
không
thời gian mà khách hàng và
admin
thì chắc sau đây là em xin
demo trang web của em
đầu tiên thì các người dùng có thể tìm
kiếm lịch đặc của mình
chọn giờ
có thể khi mà đặt son ngay thì có thể
chọn cho họ giờ luôn của mình
đạt được mùa xuân 2 khung giờ đúng không
nó chỉ có một kiểu đặt cái khung giờ đấy
thôi cho nó khác ngay nhưng mà khác ngay
thì có thể đạt được
còn không hay không được dùng Không ý
anh làm cái rủ anh vừa rồi em khung giờ
là một tiếng đúng không Nhưng anh muốn
chơi từ
chơi 3 tiếng thì sao
không có phải như thế thì chắc phải đặt
3 lần
người cùng đặt một khung giờ cùng một
sân được
chắc người nào đặt trước thì
chắc là sẽ được trước còn những người
sau thì chắc em bỏ lỗi chắc là nó chắc
chắn rồi
giao diện nó
dưới à
thì sân 7 đều là đâu
thử cho anh xem ví dụ xem này
sẽ không không có được thoải mái Với lại
khi mà đặt
cái này nó sẽ
bị đây
[âm nhạc]
Cái cái phần giờ này thì em kiểm tra kỹ
lắm không không không không có
nói chung được
nữa không nhỉ
không có gì nhiều
thì có thể xem xem cách săn
[Vỗ tay]
ở khu vực em
xong thì cũng chỉ
xem xóa sửa Tìm kiếm
báo lên nó bị trùng trùng giờ với cái áo
thun đó ví dụ như hóa đơn này thì nếu mà
xem
ấy nhỉ
Cái bên bên kia kìa tìm kiếm gõ Tìm kiếm
cái gì
Kiểu tên với số điện thoại với
[âm nhạc]
mà em muốn lấy chuẩn ra nó phải dựa theo
số dân nó chia theo số dân thì nó mới ra
được rất Giả sử khu vực mà ít sân để làm
sao ở khu vực đấy nhiều đơn hơn với khu
vực nhiều sân được đúng không Nó phải có
tỷ lệ
ở đây cho anh tổng kết lại em em muốn
chia sẻ nốt slide không lại về Cái
bây giờ nếu có giả sử Cho Em Thêm Một
tháng nữa chẳng hạn thì em nghĩ em cần
bổ sung thêm tính năng gì Em muốn làm
thêm tính năng gì
người ta chọn kiểu mình mình làm cái
chọn chọn sân hay kiểu
mình vào cái giờ đấy Sao mà mình ý là
làm cái giao diện cái sân luôn kiểu nó
là cái icon hay là gì ấy cho nó xỉn xíu
quyết một vài tán tương đối là phải đặt
sân Tìm sân và cũng có tính thống kê
cũng có hiển thị cũng giải quyết được
cái bài toán đó là nếu mà đặt chung thì
sao nó là bài toán nghiệp vụ ổn rồi
nhưng mà nhưng mà Thì cái bài toán quản
lý sân của em ấy thì nó vẫn chưa tiện
làm cho người dùng đúng không ấn vào bên
khu vực hay sân Thì vừa rồi em sẽ thấy
kiểu nó vẫn kiểu nó vẫn chung chung nó
vẫn kiểu đầy đủ tính năng xem thêm sửa
xóa quá kiểu nó không
Cái này thì bây giờ anh ốp cái giao diện
này nhảy sang làm bán cái khác cũng được
Bây giờ đặt vé xem phim cũng được không
cần nhất thiết phải liên quan đến việc
sơn sùng này các thứ
nghĩa là bài toán nghiệp vụ về quản lý
sân Thì nó vẫn
chưa có lắm em hiểu em không
thống kê ý anh à Nó vẫn chưa tiện về
việc quản lý sân lắm quản lý theo khu
vực mà cả là bởi vì em mới làm mỗi một
đối tượng amin thôi Đáng lẽ có những cái
đối tượng mà chủ sân cơ mình sẽ Min nó
làm kiểu khác chủ sân để làm kiểu khác
cơ anh cơ thể hoặc là giống như bây giờ
là Nếu giả sử khách đến đến trực tiếp để
mà đặt sân thì mình sẽ làm như thế nào
đặt ở họ vào trang bên khách hàng đặt À
các bạn chưa nghĩ đến thật nhưng mà ý
anh là giả sử bài toán như thế thì em sẽ
giải quyết như thế nào
nghĩa là theo em thì nên giải quyết thế
nào chứ không phải em có hay chưa nhé
Theo em giải quyết như nào kiểu
giờ tại vào cái khu đấy Xong rồi lựa cái
xoong xong rồi lựa cái giờ xong rồi mình
tự mình mình làm cái đơn
và nói chung là giao diện có thể na ná
giống kiểu linh kiện cũng được đúng
không
là mình không đạt được nhiều sân cùng
lúc thì đấy là một cái trở ngại đúng
không
phải nhiều sân cùng lúc mà đặt
đúng không
không sao cái Đạp sân này nó chỉ đang mô
phỏng việc là em có hình dung được cách
làm hay không thì anh thấy là đúng em
làm được theo kiểu là đầy đủ về cái việc
là
input input proset và output rồi input
của các bạn à input của em đang hơi hơi
vẫn còn hơi thủ công quá nhỉ
thì input ở đây được cả anh cũng không
biết được làm thế nào cho tiện người
dùng để mà nhập được nhiều sân cùng một
lúc nữa về đây đang có nhiều quá nha Còn
Nhưng cái đấy thì lúc đầu có anh có sẵn
nhiều sân đúng không anh thêm vào như
nào anh có thêm thủ công như thế nào
Đấy ví dụ về cái ảnh của em thì excel
không lên được ảnh đâu nhé
sân này Thực ra là cũng chỉ để kiểm tra
tương đối thôi Ok em làm thế này về ổn
rồi Cảm ơn em nhỉ
nhóm tiếp theo nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
Xin chào thầy và các bạn là nhóm em mà
nhóm 23 và
nhóm em có bao gồm thành viên là Đinh
Hoàng Duy là em và bạn Nguyễn Văn Mạnh
thì hôm nay bạn Nguyễn Văn Mạnh bạn bận
nên em sẽ thuyết trình và nhóm em thì
hôm nay bảo vệ là đề tài mà phân công
được dạy
là công nghệ thông tin ngày càng phát
triển vì vậy chúng ta cần phải áp dụng
công nghệ thông tin và những việc thực
tế để theo kịp thời đại và cái thứ hai
là các trường học Trung tâm Giáo dục với
số lượng học viên đông nhưng mà có những
nơi vẫn sử dụng Excel và giấy tờ đã quản
lý học viên quản lý các lịch học và cái
cuối cùng lại muốn giảm bớt sức lao động
của con người và tiết kiệm thời gian và
có độ chính xác cao
về công nghệ sử dụng thì nhóm em bao gồm
sử dụng html5 css3 travelite S6 Siri
phiên bản 3.4 BHD phiên bản 7.4
sinh viên là có thể xem lịch học và điểm
danh các Xem điểm danh các bội bán giảng
viên là có thể xem lịch dạy học
điểm danh lớp học còn trưởng khoa thì có
bao gồm tính năng của một diễn viên và
thêm vào đó có tính năng là xây dựng
chương trình đào tạo phân công lịch dạy
phân công lập dạy học Xem lịch dạy học
của tất cả các lớp thuộc Khoa mình và
phòng tuyển sinh đào tạo thì có quản lý
hệ đào tạo nên khóa khoa ngành học môn
học và sinh viên còn quản trị viên thì
có thể truy cập tại huyện Vào website và
có thể quản lý các giảng viên
đầu tiên là nhóm em có khoa thì một khoa
thì có nhiều ngành và một ngành thì
thuộc kỹ thuật một pha và sau đó thì một
ngành thì có nhiều lớp và một lớp chỉ
thuộc một ngành và sắc trong có lớp thì
một lớp thì có nhiều sinh viên còn một
sinh viên thì chỉ được thuộc một lớp
sau đó thì có giảng viên
giảng viên Thì một pha thì có nhiều diễn
viên nhưng mà một diễn viên chỉ được
thuần mộc khoa còn môn học thì một khoa
thì có nhiều môn học còn một môn học chỉ
thuộc một pha
nhiều lịch một lớp thì có nhiều lực phân
công
[âm nhạc]
và
ăn một lớp có nhiều lần phân công và một
lần phân công thì chỉ được một lớp thôi
và
cái lịch phân công mà cái sinh viên thì
có quan hệ là nhiều nhiều thì xin thì có
cái nên tạo ra cái bảng là điểm danh thì
điểm danh là nó gồm mã lực và mã sinh
viên
nữa không ạ
vậy tiếp đến em có sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu
thì
và sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu thì ở đây em có
bảng simment thì là để luôn lịch dạy học
cũng là để xem lịch học của cái sinh
viên thì ở đây có Dead là để luôn ngày
có listen start là để luôn
Tin học bắt đầu và Listen and rễ luôn
chứ học kết thúc có classroom 3D là để
luôn mã lớp học và có sắp xếp AD để luôn
môn học và có cái chợ đây là để luôn
mã giáo viên dạy
có cục status để luôn tình trạng lớp học
đó Ở đây còn có bản blend này là để phân
để cho trưởng khoa phân công tạo cái
có trang tin là cái hệ đào tạo tại vì
website của em nhắm đến có nhiều hệ tại
vì có những hệ là giống như hệ cao đẳng
hoặc là trung cấp là đại học nhưng
cái này đâu có trong thực thể đâu nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
lens là như nào ấy nhỉ
như hệ đào tạo thì giống như mình học ở
đại học thì có 4 năm thì tương đương là
8 học kỳ thì ở đây nó sẽ lưu giống như
là học kỳ 1 là học môn nào đó học kỳ 2
là học môn nào
ban đầu nên là cái database này em đang
rối
cái đoạn này có thể thua hoặc thiếu
đấy đoạn này bây giờ nhé cái
bây giờ nếu như em đang làm ví dụ điển
hình về mỗi cái Plan thôi đúng không
Nghĩa là cùng cùng một khoa hai lớp có
thể học một môn ở học kỳ khác nhau
đúng không cùng một bây giờ ấy đúng
không
Tại vì cái này là do giống như hai lớp
thì mỗi lớp là một ngành ấy nhỉ nên là
có thể là ngành này học cái môn này
trước ngành này học môn này sau
không đã nói cùng một ngành mà
[âm nhạc]
khoa giống như là khoa công nghệ thông
tin thì có ngành
quản trị mạng hay là gì đó
không em phải loại không
rồi đúng không Môn lại thuộc Khoa thuộc
ngành đúng không
nhưng mà vừa nãy anh hỏi cậu một lớp mà
cùng chung một ngành đúng không Hai lớp
chung một ngành đi học môn nó khác học
kỳ à
nếu mà hai lớp chung một ngành thì có
thể là ví dụ là nó có cái hệ đào tạo ở
đây giống như là
đào tạo của Cao đẳng thì nó sẽ khác đại
học thì nó sẽ học cái
đúng không
[âm nhạc]
Tại sao có listen start và Listen and Nó
là cái gì nhỉ
là buổi sáng là 6 tết buổi chiều là 6
tết
vì có thể hỏng một tiết hoặc là hai tiết
còn ca thì nó
bắt buộc theo khung giờ
thôi ok
một ngày
bị sao nhé Ok
classroom suck
[âm nhạc]
sai
ở Simon này nó là điểm danh à
là
ngày 29 thì tiết bắt đầu là tiết mục và
chức năng thì có lớp giống như lớp của
mình và môn thế kỷ lập trình web thì
mình có cái add mình lấy cái ID này mình
bỏ vô cái bảng ntn và mình thêm mã của
Steel thì nó sẽ
giới hạn cái bảng phân công nó khác với
bảng điểm danh nó khác nhé
phân công thì chỉ cần phân công một lần
thôi điểm danh điểm danh nhiều nếu mà em
làm theo kiểu là phân công ở đây thế này
đồng nghĩa việc là có bao nhiêu lớp thì
sẽ phải phân công bấy nhiêu lần
đúng không
Dạ Đúng rồi là một ngày một
buổi học là nó sẽ vào mục và vào một
dòng dữ liệu ở Simon
Anh hiểu cái đấy Nhưng mà quan trọng là
ai là người phân công rồi đấy
trường qua một ngày vào phải ngồi cập
nhật
ví dụ có 10 lớp 10 lớp xong rồi học
một ngày hai một ngày hai môn chẳng hạn
nhập 20 lớp à Nhập 20 cái bàn ghi vào
trong bảo phân công
em dựa vào cái bảng mà sao mà em tính
toán ở và cái bạn tiết tiết học giống
như là một tiết học là nó có redit ở đây
là
số tín chỉ rồi thì em lấy 15 nhân cho em
quy định là 15 một tín chỉ là 15 tiếng
thì em lấy số tín chỉ em nhầm cho số
tiết nè thì nó sẽ ra tổng số tiết học
mình tổng số tiếp mà cái lớp phải học để
dựa vào cái bảng này xem mình em dựa vào
cái Listen and
[âm nhạc]
bảng này nó vẫn là bảng điểm danh không
phải bảng phân công phân công thì bản
chất cái tên của nó nói lên tất cả nó là
phân công là
bảng điểm danh đúng không điểm danh thì
theo ngày chứ phân công là phân công một
lần thôi Anh nãy giờ anh em nói phân
công và phân công mấy lần em bảo phân
công nhiều lần thì thế là sai phân công
nhiều lần thì ám chị ạ là phân công có
sự thay đổi thì mới gọi là phân công còn
phân công theo kiểu ngày hôm sau chẳng
khác gì ngày hôm trước gì cả thì thì
mình lặp lại nhiều bản ghi thế nó chẳng
có nghĩa gì cả đúng không
trừ khi là giáo viên của em Linh hoạt là
hôm nay thuê giáo viên này hôm ngày mai
chưa chắc có giáo viên này thì giáo viên
khác nhảy vào dạy nghĩa là mỗi ngày có
thể một giáo viên thì thì cái bảng này
nó còn hợp lý còn nếu mà em làm theo
kiểu là nó cố định là giáo viên xuyên
suốt cả Môn đấy với cái lớp đấy
thậm chí với cái tiết này luôn số tiết
như thế chẳng qua là ngày thay đổi thì
bảng phân công nó sẽ bảng riêng và sẽ
lấy cái mã của phân công đấy lưu lại vào
trong cái bảng này là bản điểm danh thì
bản điểm danh này sẽ chỉ có thay đổi mỗi
ngày thôi Đúng chưa
[âm nhạc]
Nói chung là cái base này anh chưa duyệt
chắc chắn anh chưa duyệt của ông này ông
Tự vẽ ra chứ Rõ là tôi không hề diệt mấy
cái bảng kia ông tự ý sửa nó
tham gia không tôi đuổi ông xuống rồi
Kiểu này không chấp nhận được không
Không sư tự ý sửa bay xong rồi Kiểu lên
bảo vệ chết Ok thử để mua đi xem nào
trưởng khoa trước đến
đây là bên trưởng khoa thì có thể xem
lịch học lịch dạy của mình
cái này hiện điểm danh
thì ở đây là nếu mà lớp đi đầy đủ thì
chỉ cần nhấn luôn thôi là sẽ đi đầy đủ
Còn nếu mà
không bán hay cái gì thì mình tích
thì
ở đây mình chọn lớp các lớp thuộc Khoa
của mình xong rồi học kỳ mình sẽ thêm
cái môn đó vào
thì sau khi thanh thì mình có thể xem
chi tiết ở đây ạ
Cái học kỳ mình lớp này phải học những
môn nào thì sau khi mình xếp được chương
trình đào tạo thì mình sẽ phân công phân
công giáo viên thì mình chỉ được phân
công những giáo viên mà thuộc Khoa của
mình thôi thì ở đây mình chọn giáo viên
xong rồi mình thêm những buổi chạy vào
[âm nhạc]
thêm thì mình có thể xem được những lớp
mà mình phân công
tạm ngừng nếu mà mình có thể cập nhật nó
ra mình Cập nhật lại
[âm nhạc]
mềm xịn như nào đấy
liên tục nhưng mà trông phải khó dùng em
ạ em thấy khó dùng không em tự code em
cảm thấy khó dùng không
[âm nhạc]
Anh thấy phần nào khó dùng chỉ phần nào
dễ dùng ngoài tính năng thêm sửa xóa
những cái thông tin
thôi ông khó dùng Ông còn bấm loạn
điểm danh sẽ hết Xong rồi
địa
trận thôi chậm thôi
bình tĩnh chậm thôi ok
nhấn điểm danh
rồi
thấy em làm với quả database như thế là
làm được đến bây giờ là ngon rồi nhưng
mà Thế là do database của ông lại xong
rồi Cái này chắc chắn là tôi cũng chưa
hề diệt qua cả về demo ông luôn hôm nay
lần đầu tiên tôi nhìn thấy ông làm demo
đấy
[âm nhạc]
thành ra kiểu hôm nay cứ xoắn quẩy
đối tượng còn có ở sinh viên còn xem
được lịch học mình à
Làm cái vụ đấy chưa
lời dạy
và điểm danh thì đấy là của diễn viên
còn bây giờ anh đến sinh viên
học trong tuần và
[âm nhạc]
xin được thông tin và
giao diện này Chung quen cực cái cái
hiển thị ra tuần trước tuần sau này sau
Hiển thị các thứ kiểu như này thay vì
quyển lịch Anh thề không quen cực từng
xem cái cái trang này thường Ông đúng
không xem xem
tham khảo cái trang của trường Ông xem
cái tín chỉ đúng không sống hết luôn
chưởng
rồi không biết thế nào nhưng chắc chắn
là cái này không thể tiện
Cái này là do ông khảo sát sai làm cho
tao này xong rồi cậu thôi Nói chung là
Thực ra anh thấy tư duy em làm mọi thứ
vừa rồi cốt cả mai đết cứ thử ổn rồi
không biết có thống kê chưa thôi nhưng
mà đầu vào nhập vào và xử lý là ổn rồi
đầu ra thì chưa biết kết quả nha Nhưng
mà giao diện này giao diện em đang tham
khảo là chưa Chuẩn có khó dùng ấy
em em bấm em hết cả lên đấy Được Nói như
người khác bấm
tập trung vào cái xếp lịch
ông
tôi nhắc nhở riêng ông thôi Bởi vì ông
chưa quá tôi chữa nên thành ra nó mới
thế Nhiều nhóm khác thì tôi bị tôi ném
đá lâu rồi mấy ông ấy cứ ngồi sửa ra tao
bay ngồi sai các thứ Ok cảm ơn em nhỉ Có
gì em gửi CV anh xem nhé
[âm nhạc]
xin phép trình bày về đồ ăn của nhóm 28
đồ án để website
như dòng người dùng thiết kế hệ thống và
kết luận
về phần mở đầu thì do em thấy rằng là
khi mọi người ở trong công ty ở trong
công ty nhỏ thường là họ.com bằng cách
là thủ công không có các phần mềm ra bây
giờ tốn thời gian cả việc chấm công về
tính lương cho kế toán
phần mềm để đơn giản hóa với thời gian
của việc chấm công và cũng như tính
lương
Kiếm kiểm soát cái dòng
thực hiện cái thời gian từ khi là chấm
công đến nhà tính lương và nhận lương và
xác nhận là việc đã nhận lương hay chưa
và công nghệ của em sử dụng thì gồm có
là PSP
7.43 máy SQL 5S
là yêu cầu khi chức năng thì yêu cầu là
giao diện người dùng dễ hiểu đẹp để được
tính năng và thuận tiện cho người sử
dụng cũng như là sử dụng khác nhau
về phân tích phân tích Chức năng theo
từng đối tượng thì đầu tiên là về CEO
[âm nhạc]
nhân viên xem và xác nhận là đã xác nhận
xong việc
xem và sửa Lấy tiền phạt xem và sửa quản
lý vị trí phòng ban bạn xem thêm sửa
choáng xem thêm sửa xóa thì bao gồm cả
là lương theo vị trí của bạn và lấy
lương luôn
thì em để chế ra ở bên CEO tiếp đó là về
kế toán kế toán thì gồm có chức năng sau
đăng nhập đăng xuất chấm công hàng ngày
xem lịch sử chấm công cá nhân quản lý
lương cá nhân xem và sẽ nhận là đã nhận
lương quản lý lương của phòng ban theo
quản lý lương các phòng ban được phân
công không có xem và
quản lý
thì cũng là chức năng là đăng nhập đăng
xuất.com hàng ngày sẽ được sửa cho con
cá nhân quản lý lương cá nhân của một xe
mà xác nhận lại Zalo ngoài ra thì gồm có
chức năng như là quản lý lịch sử chấm
công của phòng ban xem và xác nhận đã
xác nhận là hết tháng là phân công nhiệm
vụ cho kế toán chỉ có đối với lại nhân
viên là quản lý của phòng kế toán mà ký
xác nhận lương đối với toàn doanh nghiệp
là đối với quản lý của phòng kế toán tức
là kế toán
Hàng ngày xem lịch sử chúng không cá
nhân quản lý được cá nhân và xác nhận đã
nhận lương
thì còn có 41 tất cả Đó là quản lý nhân
viên kế toán và
bản ghi bản ghi bản ghi.com thì mỗi một
đối tượng là như là kế toán nhân viên và
quản lý thị Đại chỉ có một bản
nhiều bản
nhiều bản ghi về chúng không hàng ngày
thì bộ bàn ghế thuộc về một đối tượng là
nhân viên kế toán hoặc là quản lý tiếp
đó là phòng ban vị trí thì sẽ có 50
tượng phòng ban vị trí nhân viên quản lý
và kế toán thì mỗi nhân viên quản lý hệ
kế toán thì đều thuộc về một phòng ban
và thuộc đều có một vị trí riêng trong
vòng
quản lý sẽ quản sẽ quản lý 1/3 giờ cũng
như việc học bạn đó và một kế toán thì
sẽ quản lý bảng lương của một phòng ban
và 1/3 sẽ có nhiều vị trí
tiếp đó là bảng lương thì còn có 5 đối
tượng đó là
ăn thực tế Đó là quản lý vị trí nhân
viên kế toán CEO và bản ghi lương thì
mỗi
kế toán nhân viên và quản lý thì mỗi
người sẽ đều có một bản ghi lương trong
vòng một tháng và mỗi bản ghi này chỉ
thuộc về một người tức là sẽ là nhân
viên kế toán và quản lý điểm có nhiều
bản đi lựa và
đăng ký lương thì do bản ghi lương tạo
ra được tạo bởi một nhân
viên quản lý và
nâng đấy sẽ được ký bởi một
xác nhận và tiếp đó là đến là nhân viên
kế toán trưởng sẽ nhân viên tăng trưởng
là Manager của phòng kế toán thì sẽ là
ký xác nhận và cuối cùng là tiếp theo đó
là CEO và xác nhận là đồng ý với và cho
phép nhận lương và gửi lời xác nhận
lương thì implay sẽ ký vào đấy thì
employe giống với lại vai trò của quản
lý cũng như là kế toán để mọi người đăng
ký
ở trên này thì em có biết thiếu mất ở
phần ký cá nhân lương của bên quản lý
cái kia là một nhân viên có một bảng
lương à
là một Nó là 5-ear thì đúng
em Nếu thấy em phải trình bày rõ ràng
đau mắt quá
quản lý thì được
kế toán quản lý và CEO tiếp đó là phòng
ban
về phòng 3 nhân viên kế toán quản lý thì
đều có các trường như là ID Apple
thành phố quận huyện số điện thoại email
password
[âm nhạc]
ở đây có những bạn bạn quan trọng của
cái phần mềm của
phần mềm về điểm danh và ở trong công và
tính lương thì đầu tiên là bảng chấm
công là quan trọng và để chấm công được
thì cần khoảng thời gian chấm công là
quyết định về
tính lương thì liên quan đến tính bởi vì
mỗi lần
lấy ra xem ngày đi làm đủ hay không để
ra cái lương mà cái mức phạt
một bản ghi có những bản ghi của
do phân biệt và cái này nói là empid vào
thì em
cả nhân viên kế toán và quản lý có thể
trùng nhau mất
chỉnh à
Bởi vì thứ nhất là về ngày thứ hai là
ngày chủ công thứ hai là về
cái vai trò của công ty Tức là nhân viên
quản lý hay kế toán
database của chú rồi
Kiểu khá là kiểu hot code một vài cái
nhưng mà thôi nó vẫn kiểu nó vẫn vẫn áp
dụng được bài toán
mình thử sang demo dãy hình dung hơn nhỉ
là đăng nhập thành công và nếu thành lập
đầu tiên ở trang chủ thì em sẽ hiển thị
ra là thời gian chấm công của các ca
cũng như là thời gian
đó thì chấm công thì em sẽ ấn vào check
sau khi track xong thì nó sẽ
dùng em gửi tiếp là Asus để gửi dữ liệu
lên và nhận rượu về và sau đó xem ẩn đi
không cho phép ở lại
[âm nhạc]
tiếp đó là Xem về lịch sử chấm công thì
lịch sử công em là Lịch Sử theo tháng
thì nếu ngày không đi thì nó sẽ là đỏ an
toàn Còn nếu có ca đi lạc thì sẽ có
tương tự với lại cái
ví dụ ngày nay 29 là ca thứ ba buổi tối
thì đây Có ca là phần
check in thì do là không đi
đi với một ảnh
nó không thuộc về cái muộn mà là cũng
không phải là chỉ là đi đi quá muộn hoặc
là quên mất rồi.com
việc thay đổi việc em có thể xem theo
tháng trước
chắc là từng tháng và thể thời năm có
thể
bởi vì lịch sử trên các em chỉ làm trong
demo trong một vài tháng gần đây ra
những năm trước đó thì không có
chỉ đến cái tháng cái mình có thể xem
được đến năm 18
bên
Manager để làm ra phần luồng bởi vì đây
phần lương thì em chưa có lương của
tháng này em chưa làm xong em chưa xác
nhận xong em muốn làm cả quy trình
lại bên của nhân viên nhưng mà là thêm
một cái nữa quay riêng biệt nữa đó là về
phần quản lý điểm danh của nhân viên thì
quản lý ngành trang phục bạn trong vòng
3 tuần qua
công thì em có thể xét về tháng trước
tức là em thêm em quy định thì vào đầu
tháng là ngày từ mùng 1 đến ngày mùng 5
là sẽ được phép cái việc là cho phép xác
nhận việc tính lương của tháng trước bởi
vì thường là đầu tháng như này em vào
ngày này thì nó sẽ hiện luôn là cầu kỳ
này thì nó sẽ quay lại và ấn vào nhân
viên
như em đang là hẹn thấy đây thì nó còn
phone là không hoạt động bởi vì do là
nhân viên này đã được cái bảng lương của
nhân viên này đã được xác nhận rồi
Ok rồi và đã gửi lên bên kế toán để
nhân viên thứ hai này thì em mới vừa làm
xong em đã tạm thời là gửi đi để làm quy
trình thì sắp đến confirm thì nó sẽ
thông báo là
chính xác hay chưa bình thường
bình thường và nếu confirm thì nó sẽ là
quay lại về Cái giao diện cũ giao diện
về cái lịch sử chấm công của Ban đầu cái
của tháng đấy thì sau khi xem lại thì nó
còn Phương đã bị disable
bên kế toán thì bên kế toán sẽ là bên
xác nhận tiếp theo trước khi mà chuyển
tạm bảng lương ấy là bên kế toán thì sau
khi ngay tại thời điểm nhân viên những
việc quản lý tạo ra cái
nhân viên thường đã điểm danh Ok trong
tháng đấy thì nó sẽ tạo ra bảng lương
luôn và những cái toán chỉ được xem xét
lại và xác nhận
Thực ra thì nó em Em chưa làm nổi bật nó
lên là kiểu nó khác biệt gì so với tháng
trước nó không nó kiểu dạng là mình khó
mà kiểu Bởi vì bây giờ có rất nhiều nhân
viên đúng không em đương nhiên là việc
của người ta vẫn là người chết rồi nhưng
mà làm sao cho người ta check nó tiện ấy
thì mình có thể kiểu dạng là mình so
thường là so với tháng trước mà sau là 3
tháng trước đấy trung bình chẳng hạn
là mức lương của họ mà có thay đổi gì
nhiều không Mình sẽ kiểu thấy thực ra
không thay đổi gì nhiều thường là mình
cũng kiểu cho qua Duyên thẳng luôn chứ
không phải ngồi check kỹ lại
người không tăng ca kiểu gì cả
nào nó không có chỗ để cho việc này xem
là lương tháng trước Tháng trước nó so
sánh để so sánh
kiểu xoay mức lương có thể nói nhanh thì
có thể là bỏ hết đi mức lương cuối cùng
ạ nhưng mà cuối cùng ảnh hưởng
mức lương trung bình trung bình Mấy
tháng gần đây thôi
thế bởi vì bởi vì cái mức overtime ấy
thì em xác định như em đang làm ấy thì
đây em Em thực tế ạ em cũng không Em chỉ
là làm lương hết ca tối và chủ nhật em
nó hơi nhiều rồi sao bình thường tận
mười mấy kiểu gần ngang bằng với lại mức
lương cơ bản
Mặc dù là hơi sai Theo luật nhưng mà tức
là nó cũng khá cao ấy tức là có những
tháng không làm thì có tháng làm nó sẽ
khác
đầu em làm cái lương over time nó đã
kiểu lớn thôi mà còn Ý anh là cái tổng
lương ấy tổng lương của tháng này so với
tháng trước ấy
cũng vất vả cho kế toán đúng không
đầu em có dự kiến là sẽ ẩn đi những cái
phần mà là đã chưa làm mới có làm nhưng
mà em
những nhân viên mà chưa được upload
mùng 5 đến ngày mùng 10
ký nữa Tức là nó kệ luôn đấy
toán không làm việc thì em chưa làm cái
gì đấy
lương ký xét nghiệm tạo bảng lương đấy
thì thời gian chờ sẽ là người ký tiếp
theo để xác nhận là
lương và nhân viên có một cột sai thì sẽ
có 3 trạng thái thứ nhất là 1 2 và 3 thì
trở thành nôn Tức là chưa ký 1 và 1 tức
là khi mà nhân viên kế toán trưởng
còn 2 tức là khi
nhân viên xác nhận là đã nhận lương
lương hay chưa của ký sinh nhật là cho
phép dự án bắt đầu phát lương đến nhân
viên
em đã bắt đầu em làm cũng như của bên kế
toán và bên những cái quản lý của phòng
kế toán thì nó cũng là ký xong nó sẽ ẩn
hiện đi Nhưng mà thế thì một cái lỗi là
không biết là những ai đã là đã được xác
nhận rồi
người dùng nữa vài cái đây em Em thử thử
nói gì con con em tính năng gì nữa nhỉ
Có đây thứ nhất là về bên nốt phần chấm
công và tính lương
đây ạ
không phải là ngày ký lương ở trong ngày
15 đến ngày 20 gì đó là trong không gian
đấy
Cái này em cũng không nghĩ em chưa làm
được nếu sau đó muộn thì như thế nào
Ok bỏ qua đi còn bây giờ để tiện hơn cho
Bây giờ em có những đối tượng là tưởng
là nhân viên kế toán kế toán trưởng và
quản lý đúng không
Thì theo có cả quản lý nữa đúng không
tính năng gì tiện cho chính nó
chữa ảnh có vậy
nó có ảnh hưởng thế nào Thống kê về mức
lương
mỗi tháng xem ai là lên đầu thấy là cao
nhất đấy
thứ hai là về cái buổi điểm danh của
nhân viên tức là thống kê của cả phòng
bạn là những ai đã đi muộn nhiều nhất
toán trưởng thì sao bây giờ Nếu giả sử
mà là xử ở đây em mới chỉ ký xác nhận
thôi em Nếu giả sử mà kế toán làm sai
thì mình làm như nào
nếu nhân viên chấm công lỗi Tức là nó có
thể nó không đi nhưng mà nó nhờ đâu ở
trên app thì quản lý làm được cái gì
quản lý không sửa được chủ công của nhân
viên thứ hai là về bảng lương tạo ra và
nước tạo ra mà có lỗi thì Kế toán cũng
không sửa được bảng lương hiện tại chưa
làm được đấy phải sửa được mới đúng ạ
được Phần đấy em cho làm
việc làm xe thêm mà xem được các thứ
thôi đúng không
của bên kia quản lý chỉ gồm có là
phân công phân công cái phòng ban mà để
cho việc kiểm toán quản lý
kế toán sức quản lý toàn bộ cái bảng
lương thì em có ra một trang là để quản
lý
mức phạt em mặc định bởi vì ở đây được
thời gian thì do mặc định có 3k em không
cho phép thêm thêm Bởi vì ngày xưa có
thêm nhưng mà sẽ gây ra lỗi thì em
nhưng mà thay đổi xong thì bạn không
nghĩ đến việc như thay đổi xong thì ảnh
hưởng bao giờ áp dụng thì em suy nghĩ về
đấy ạ Bởi vì khi nghe thời điểm em sửa
bây giờ thì nó ảnh hưởng đến trực tiếp
hệ thống bây giờ và ảnh hưởng cả
tính bắt đầu từ khi là hết thời gian
check in đến thời gian check in L1
có thể tham từ khi lấy 2 đi lên 2-1 và
Elly 1 only hai cũng thế thì sinh ra cái
bảng file này thì theo tương tự là thực
tế thì cái bảng cái bảng này không phải
do em làm do do cái
bạn trong nhóm nhưng mà Đấy Hiện tại
đang nghỉ rồi Mày làm em thấy
này thì thực tế thì
nó không phép sửa bởi vì bình thường
này phải đuổi theo mà thay thời gian của
cái này thay đổi theo thì phải thay đổi
theo 3k với 3k
muộn đi chết Cuối Cùng remix
[âm nhạc]
hoặc là
sửa và xóa hoặc là bị thí điểm về logic
thì em sẽ sau khi nếu mà soạn sửa vị trí
thì sửa Toàn ảnh sẽ sửa theo là toàn bộ
các nhân viên trong công an này cái vị
trí đấy hoặc là xóa thì một là yêu cầu
là trước khi phải xóa và chuyển hết Nhân
viên trong phòng bạn ấy sang phòng ăn
khác hoặc là nó sẽ bị xóa hoàn toàn đi
và nó sẽ để sang về là trống ạ
cái này không cắt À
confession này thì đều em không test em
lúc nào phần này ạ
ok rồi Con còn gì muốn chia sẻ nữa không
nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
Ok cảm ơn bạn nhé nhiều tính năng là bày
rất lằng nhằng
Ok em ok
Ok rồi Ok rồi
Đồ ăn này thì em làm về website đặt xe ô
tô tự lái
thực thể cơ sở dữ liệu và cuối cùng là
để mua
đầu tiên là mình Lý do là người Việt Nam
thì mình
di chuyển đi lại thì ô tô bằng ô tô thì
vẫn như là ô tô khá là
mụn chi phí môtô Việt Nam khá là cao nên
là sinh ra Website để sinh ra công ty
này để giúp mọi người thuê được xe lại
muốn về quê dễ dàng hơn và giúp cho công
ty quản lý thì
đỡ phải xử lý nhiều giấy tờ
khó bị Nếu mà nhiều giấy tờ quá thì nó
sẽ bị
rất khó quản lý
tượng là khách là xem là quản trị viên
khách đặt xe thì có đăng nhập đăng ký
đăng xuất bình thường có khả năng nhập
vào bằng Google có tìm xe đặt xe và xem
danh sách xe đã đặt
quản trị viên Duyệt hay chưa
tiếp theo là quản trị viên thì có đăng
nhập đăng xuất quản lý người dùng thì có
thể sửa thông tin người dùng hoặc thêm
thêm chứng minh nhân dân hoặc là thêm
giấy phép lái xe quản lý ô tô thì
xem thêm sửa xóa ô tô
Cập nhật trạng thái của ô tô
hóa đơn thì lý hóa đơn thì chị biết
có thể tạo hóa đơn và
tìm xe để xong rồi tạo hóa đơn rồi
lái xe và căn cước công dân của người
dùng
đây là sơ đồ thực thể và Google cơ sở dữ
liệu thì một người dùng thì có thể tạo
ra nhiều hóa đơn và hóa đơn thì được chỉ
việc tạo ra bởi một người dùng
mỗi dòng xe thì
mỗi một xe thì có thể có nhiều hóa đơn
nhưng mà
một hóa đơn chỉ có một xe
gần đây là database của em
trong sơ đồ thể nhỉ cái file
cơ sở liệu mà cái thức thể nào để tạo ra
được cái bảng file
ra database
Ok
như em vừa bảo bảo file nó là điểm gì
nhỉ và Để em lưu kiểu căn cước công dân
lưu ảnh lưu ảnh của căn cước của người
dùng Xong rồi ảnh của xe hoặc có thể ảnh
hóa đơn
kiểu nó là sẽ phân loại bằng 2 và
chẳng hạn user sẽ là một này Bill là 2k3
xong rồi table ID là những cái ID ở mỗi
bản tương ứng
mỗi ảnh kiểu của nó hoàn thành căn cước
công dân thì hoặc là ảnh của xe là ảnh
hóa đơn nhiều nhiều loại
có những cột gì trên hình dung được lắm
thì là sẽ là ảnh của biển số xe còn
những cái ảnh chi tiết thì em sẽ lưu vào
trong bảng file
Đây là địa chỉ để chẳng hạn người dùng
Tìm kiếm theo địa chỉ thì nó sẽ ra những
cái xe ở trong địa chỉ ấy chẳng hạn như
Hà Nội thì xong rồi nó sẽ hiện ra những
danh sách xe và cái chẳng hạn số hàng
Đào hay là hàng gì đó
còn sót
bản của xe
slot slot số chỗ đúng không
Hai kiểu là như kiểu là xe
[âm nhạc]
xe tải
ngày thuê và giá dịch vụ giá
tiền bảo hiểm kiểu Nếu mà dịch vụ là
kiểu
mình sau mỗi lần lấy Khách hàng thuê thì
mình phải có tiền dịch vụ bảo dưỡng xe
và tiền bảo hiểm là chẳng hạn như là
tiền bảo hiểm nếu mà có chẳng may xước
xát gì thì mỗi mỗi bảo hiểm
Giá mỗi xe thì khác nhau nhưng mà mỗi
bảo hiểm này thì sẽ có
anh Nếu mà anh có xước xát gì thì công
ty sẽ bù cho anh chẳng hạn bao nhiêu
phần trăm hóa đơn kiểu
Ok
[âm nhạc]
những cột như nào nhỉ
xe người ta thuê ở đây thì em sẽ chỉ
sử dụng ngày tháng năm thôi không sử
dụng thời gian thì xe là thuê mỗi ngày
ngày bắt đầu ngày kết thúc và
ngày
thực tế kết thúc thì có thể người ta sẽ
quá hạn xe
mà nếu mà quá hạn thì nhân viên sẽ gọi
điện cho
gọi điện cho khách hàng và
kết thúc xong rồi sẽ có giá phạt tiền
Drive
đây giá phạt là kiểu Nếu mà
[âm nhạc]
tạo ra đây này thì em nghĩ đến vấn đề là
giá phạt thì mình sẽ chỉ ghi ngoài giấy
tờ thôi nhưng mà trên code thì hiện tại
là em quên mất là có cả vụ này
theo xe mà đúng không
không không thuê xe có xe giá trị giá
phạt nó khác theo ngày chứ
lúc đầu thì người dùng sẽ không nhất
thiết phải là
ấy những cái ngày này không biết là anh
em tính click Chuột Không cái này hơi
khó nhìn em
ấy là sẽ không chọn được ngày trước đó
cũng đã vài nét rồi
Bên này thì nó sẽ tự động
tự động ấy lại bắt buộc cái này phải lớn
hơn ngày 30 của cái này em nhập ở đây
tháng sau thì cái chỗ này sẽ bị hủy đi
và nó sẽ bắt ấy lại gặp lại đây ngày 5
nên nó sẽ không được chọn nữa Cái này em
cũng đã có file điếc rồi
giờ thì không biết test kiểu gì về cái
này em không cho ấn nữa
thì sẽ có danh sách xe và
chi tiết thì nó sẽ hiện thông báo bây
giờ các thông tin cơ bản cái đoạn cái
filter này thì hơi mất thời gian để em
chưa làm được ngại em muốn filter tính
năng bổ sung là filter theo số xe này
theo loại xe mà
số tự động sang cái gì đó
Nếu mà đặt xe thì
chưa đăng ký thì nó sẽ nhảy lại đang
đăng ký đăng nhập
đăng nhập Google
khoản Google luôn
khởi động lại session nên là nó
bắt em phải này
còn bình thường nếu mà đang đăng nhập
bình thường thôi thì nó sẽ nhảy đến cho
em Trang này luôn
Google nên là những cái thông tin cơ bản
em chưa có
điền hoặc là
để chơi Điền số điện thoại
file thì mình dùng không cần nhất thiết
người dùng
thì nhập cũng được không nhận không nhập
Thì người dùng sẽ không lấy được
có season ở đây rồi thì em sẽ vẫn sẽ tìm
kiếm được chỉ là không tìm kiếm được
những cái xe mà mình vừa đã chọn thôi
đến đây
nhiều xe cùng một lúc anh có lịch sử
ok ok
tài khoản
xem mặt trước mặt sau gì đó không phải
em em
mình sẽ chỉ được ấy đâu sửa thông tin cơ
bản này và còn chứng nguyên nhân dân căn
cước thì sửa đây
ông ông phải hỏi luôn hỏi lại chứ ông
bấm xóa Như đùa vậy
[âm nhạc]
là chưa được duyệt mà mình duyệt ở đây
thôi sau khi duyệt xong thì rửa cả hai
xong thì mình mới được nghiện cái thay
đổi trạng thái này
cái này thì tính năng tương lai em muốn
trở lại là kiểu Nếu mà đặt xe thì chỉ
chuyển lên được đã ra xe thôi hoặc là
chuyển lên được hoàn thành
những cái duyệt
trạng thái à diệt căn cước hay là giấy
phép lái xe sẽ không còn dưới này là ảnh
của chi tiết xe thuê
quản lý xe thì thêm xe cơ bản thêm xe
anh chi tiết thì không cần thiết đã có
vài đứa bạn này
ấy xong rồi tạo hóa đơn thì sao chuyển
sang quản lý xe và không còn những cái
kia nữa không Còn những cái xem sửa xóa
và đây mình có thể tìm kiếm ngay đây
luôn
xịn Cũng xịn cũng hay nhưng mà Thế bây
giờ khách hàng ấy chưa đăng ký mình tạo
luôn cả tài khoản khách hàng được không
được nhưng mà sẽ không có Gmail
Nguyễn Văn A
ok
con con tính năng gì nữa
hiện tại đến đây thôi ạ
thứ nhất là khẳng định đi khẳng định
giao diện các bạn làm vẫn rất là đẹp
giao diện này anh thấy rất
thân thiện được ổn được
bạn này làm quản lý giao diện cho ít
tính năng này giao diện
trả hết phần cần trình bày rồi Chắc là
thôi Cấm nay em nhé Em cảm ơn anh
Ok mở Nhóm tiếp theo đúng
nhóm binh alo Ok em trình bày đi
[âm nhạc]
Ok
là phần mềm tính lương cho thời gian lái
xe
có thể tiếp cận tới nhiều khách hàng hơn
và giúp cho những người bận rộn có nhu
cầu học lái có thể dễ dàng sắp xếp lịch
học của mình
E6 máy viana.7 và lavabo chính
đối tượng sử dụng có người quản trị Hệ
thống giáo viên học viên và khách Online
đó chính hệ thống có thể xem thêm xóa
giáo viên học viên chỉnh sửa xét duyệt
luôn cho giáo viên giải đáp thắc mắc của
khách hàng có email thêm các tài liệu
cho khóa học Xem tất cả các lịch học
thay đổi các thông tin trong website
về giáo viên Thì xem thông tin của các
mũi dại xem được tin và thực trạng hơn
tháng điểm danh cái buổi dạy theo từng
viên
học viên có thể thay đổi thông tin cá
nhân thay đổi được không giáo viên và
các buổi học từ ins đăng ký thêm các
buổi học và đánh giá của buổi học đã
xong
về cách online có thể đăng ký khóa học
sim có tài liệu được chia sẻ trên trang
chủ đặt các câu hỏi và nhận trả lời qua
email đánh giá cái buổi học đã xong em
nhận tư vấn thông qua
với một khóa học và một người dùng nó sẽ
có khi vừa đăng ký sẽ có được
một giáo viên
phải sắp xếp theo
giáo viên được chọn bằng cos
mỗi giáo viên có nhiều lương khác lương
tháng sẽ được cái Minh này sẽ được lưu
tháng và năm
Em sang bên tập thể sang cơ sở
tắt là khi người dùng đặt câu hỏi
cần tư vấn hoặc là câu hỏi trên trang
chủ thì sẽ được lưu về và emin sẽ trả
lời cái này nó được lưu theo hai dạng
một dạng là tư vấn với một cục dạng là
đặt câu hỏi tư vấn sẽ được tư vấn qua
điện thoại
còn câu hỏi thì trả lời qua email
khóa học thì có các khóa học
B1 B2 C
luôn có giá tiền theo cái này
được không Nó được lưu vào cổ tích
theo nếu như là người dùng đăng ký một
buổi 4 tiếng và người dùng đăng ký vượt
qua hậu thì em sẽ cho và 20 buổi Và nếu
người dùng đăng ký tập 1 buổi 2 tiếng là
full khóa thì sẽ cho 40 tuổi có sự được
lưu và con thích và có thể thay đổi đó
nếu sau này về theo quy định của Bộ giáo
dục là sẽ bao nhiêu tiếng đó bao nhiêu
giờ đó thì em lưu vào mỗi khóa có bao
nhiêu giờ được mà
[âm nhạc]
ạ
gì nữa
đăng ký và chọn chọn giáo viên nhưng
người dùng có thể thay đổi được giáo
viên ở đây và
các status này sẽ lưu theo kiểu Y5
Lưu Thiên Cốt
bảng lương này thì từ đây nó sẽ đưa ra
được chi tiết luôn
ơ qua đề môn
Ok Ok Sang đây
demode
hình như
thì nó sẽ tự bắt đó đủ 12 cái ký tự này
dễ thôi 16 nhiều bạn ghi có nhìn đoạn
này loạn lắm
không không xem theo ăn được đâu
[âm nhạc]
ạ
anh này nó
không có
sắp xếp theo trạng thái
hiểu các học viên đăng ký
Hoặc là
lúc ban đầu luôn bị trừ tức điểm ở đây
không nghe rõ cái gì nãy giờ con demo
thì anh cũng xem qua rồi cũng tương đối
tính năng các thứ rồi thống kê Này vớ
vẩn quá thống kê chẳng có tác dụng gì cả
buổi dậy
vào quan tâm ngủ dậy
lịch lịch Tuần tới mình sẽ dạy như nào
mình biết kiểu gì
không sẽ giật như anh vừa bảo đấy
một lúc được
được không hay ghi đề lịch lên nhau được
không
hai người đặt lịch học cùng lúc
được mà đúng không
kiểu 11
[âm nhạc]
rồi Ồ nó vẫn chưa trung hòa mới chỉ có
những cái tính năng là xem thêm và xem
cái vừa thêm đúng không Cũng không có
thống kê gì cả thống kê cái thống kê vừa
rồi trả giáo dụ gì em nhé Ừ có thêm cả
bạn lương nhỉ Xem lại bảng lương mà
nó dựa trên cái gì Đánh giá không dựa
trên đánh giá học viên này
em tính
Xong rồi trừ theo lương theo quy định
này ra lấy 5 sao trừ đó này
ví dụ như bình thường
điểm chủng dưới sao trung bình em có thể
trừ ví dụ 500.000 hay gì đó hay gì đó Em
trừ kia là trừ phần trăm à
theo kiểu là mình biết được tại sao mình
Phạt
Phạt nghĩa là nó sẽ thống kê được là số
số điểm đánh giá thấp là bao nhiêu xong
rồi Từ đấy quy ra mức phạt là bao nhiêu
chứ không phải trừ lương
sao như nào kiểu kia thằng thằng giáo
viên đến nó xì vào nó chửi nhau ấy
không ai hiển thị kiểu đấy cả chúng ta
mình như thế nào khác nhau nhé
giao diện hay về tính năng đều ổn rồi có
thêm vài tính năng nữa nhưng nó lại chưa
hoàn thiện được một cái một bài toán
trọn vẹn và việc là nhập vào xử lý thông
tin và xuất ra cái sự xuất gia của em
chưa có phần sự phân nhập vào của em thì
nó vẫn hơi có tí dối một tí xem nó cũng
hơi Rối
có đúng mỗi giao diện ở bên khách hàng
anh thấy còn ổn còn bên Army thì sơ sài
quá kiểu nó vẫn chỉ mang tính chất là
kiểu cơ bản chưa có gì kiểu dạng là tiện
người dùng cả
Tiện đây cực tiện nhé chứ hiển thị ra
kiểu giao diện thấy cũng được rồi nhưng
mà vẫn chưa thì tiện lắm
vào thôi nhưng mà người thống kê
cái lượng câu hỏi chưa phản hồi ra nó
còn có ý nghĩa cái số lượng kia nó không
cùng trừ khi mình hiển thị ở So sánh
giữa quá khứ với hiện tại ra còn có tác
dụng gì còn không thì cái này nó không
đem lại được ý nghĩa gì cả thôi Chú bấm
vào thì để danh sách học viên tháng này
cũng chẳng thể hiện gì cả cháu biết được
ông nào với ông nào thì xem
đúng không
bài toán dứt điểm đây là trang web về
chủ yếu là vẫn là về kiểu Tìm giáo viên
và kiểu học học
kiêm cả việc quản lý lương này quản lý
cả buổi học này
kiếm rõ nhiều nhưng mà mỗi thứ mới chỉ
mức cơ bản tí Thế thì nó phần mềm được
vẫn được tính là phần mềm sơ sài đấy bởi
vì nó chưa trọn vẹn giải quyết được dứt
điểm được một cái gì chưa có những tính
năng xịn ở trong này nhỉ
tính năng xịn nhất của em
của ông là cái gì
toàn bộ là cơ bản mà chẳng có cái gì xịn
đúng không
nhất ở đây cả đúng không
thành được một cái trang web cũng gọi là
nhiều tính năng các thứ rồi
[âm nhạc]
nhưng mà cái này nếu mà nếu mà ví dụ
muốn tung ra thị trường Chẳng hạn muốn
bán người khác thì chắc chắn là cần phải
bổ sung thêm để tiện hơn tiện hơn cho
người ta quản lý cũng như là có thống kê
hay gì gì đó Sao ok nhỉ
buổi hôm nay chắc là mình cũng kết thúc
tại đây Cảm ơn các bạn Thực ra thì
hôm nay mình cũng muốn kiểu
livestream và cũng sẽ còn lâu nữa mình
mới có thể tiếp tục livestream bởi vì là
mình tính ra là là buổi sắp tới là mình
sẽ offline ở trong Hàn trong Hồ Chí Minh
mình sẽ vào đấy offline Xong rồi
[âm nhạc]
cũng sẽ bắt đầu đi học phải dùng từ đi
học ở bên FPT để mà học xem là họ cách
họ dạy như nào vân vân bổ sung thêm tí
lý thuyết để mà chuẩn bị đi có thể sẽ
sang bên đấy Dậy
Nói chung là tháng sau sẽ
tháng sau rất là dài nhưng mà bây giờ
thực tế là chỉ còn hai hôm nữa hai hôm
nữa là làm sẽ những cái bộ phá của mình
các bạn sẽ thấy là các bạn quen mình từ
thời gian đầu cho đến bây giờ là mình
thay đổi rất nhiều rồi và chính các bạn
cũng thay đổi rất rất nhiều rồi đúng
không ạ Hôm nay là bảo vệ gần như là
cuối của tất cả các nhóm rồi các bạn sẽ
thấy là các bạn cũng đã học thêm được
một cái gì đó đã chịu cố gắng làm được
cái gì đó từ những những nhóm kiểu Kể cả
hôm nay chỉ có thể thêm xóa thôi cũng
không thực sự dành rất nhiều thời gian
cho nó nhưng mà vẫn học thêm được một
cái gì đó rồi đấy thì
chắc chắn là mình sẽ còn livestream live
code để mà thỉnh thoảng chia sẻ thêm
nhiều cái cho các bạn hoặc là tâm sự gì
đó Sao
không kênh này tôi sẽ không bỏ đâu yên
tâm và các bạn Tôi nghĩ là và cũng là
đến lúc mà gọi là tạm tạm Chào tạm biệt
các bạn để để mình sẽ cả hai sẽ cùng ra
ngoài va chạm để mà học hỏi thêm nhiều
cái những bạn nào vẫn còn muốn kiểu gặp
mình đặc biệt ở Hà Nội càng tốt mọi thì
có thể sang công ty mình để mà xem thực
tập xem thế nào cũng được Để tốt nghiệp
hiện tại thì mình chưa Mình chưa làm gì
để mà kiểu xác nhận tốt nghiệp cho mấy
ông cả đợi khi nào tôi lại kêu lên làm
một cái gì đó bên FPT to to tôi về sau
tôi sẽ làm lễ tốt nghiệp cho mấy ông lúc
đấy thì cái bằng cấp mấy ông có giá trị
hơn nhiều đấy chứng chỉ đúng không chứng
chỉ được xác nhận bởi giảng viên à giảng
viên Thì bây giờ tôi có cái mác rồi phải
chứng chỉ của
được xác nhận bởi ai thì lúc đấy mấy ông
to vãi chưởng
trẻ chán mà đúng không
hẹn gặp lại mấy ông ở ngày gần nhất và
hi vọng hi vọng lúc đấy chúng ta sẽ có
rất nhiều thứ để khoe với nhau kiểu từ
đó từ bây giờ đến lúc đó Kiểu mình đã
phát triển bản thân rất nhiều có thứ gì
khỏe
Chào các bạn nhé